Le problème des lunettes
c'est que ça fait aussi des gros reflets.
Donc on les enlève !
Salut ! Aujourd'hui je fais
la vidéo depuis Toulon.
Puisque je suis toujours sur la
tournée de "Mental Roadage".
Ça fait longtemps que je n'ai pas
parlé des forçages psychologiques sur la chaîne.
Donc,
on va faire ça.
C'est parti !
[Musique Générique]
Alors, un forçage psychologique
c'est le fait de forcer quelqu'un
à faire un choix,
le choix qu'on veut nous.
Dans les vidéos de l'année dernière,
quand je faisais une vidéo par jour,
on a déjà abordé plusieurs fois
ce sujet.
J'ai même, d'ailleurs, une vidéo qui
doit traîner sur la chaîne
d'avant que je lance
vraiment la chaîne.
Je vais vous mettre une petite fiche
par là, vous allez pouvoir y accéder.
C'en est un.
Alors forcément, si vous allez le faire
en étant prévenu :
ça va moins fonctionner.
Et oui, puisque vous êtes prévenu...
Donc forcément... moins...
Forcément tu fais attention...
Puisque tu sais que je vais te forcer...
Vous comprenez le principe.
Je ne me suis pas rapproché trop
près, encore, de cette caméra ?
Bref ! Il y a pleins de techniques
déjà pour influencer les choix,
déjà la technique de la liberté,
on en avait parlé ensemble...
Je vous avais déjà dit que vous êtes
libre de ne PAS vous abonner à la chaîne,
ce n'est pas un souci,
vous faites ce que vous voulez,
c'est pareil : vous êtes libres de
ne pas mettre un pouce en l'air,
c'est vous qui voyez.
Ce n'est pas une obligation.
C'est vraiment votre liberté
à vous.
Donc ça, c'est plutôt une
technique d'influence.
Un forçage psychologique,
c'est plus que de l'influence.
Et là je vais prendre un forçage
de Dai Vernon.
Dai Vernon, qui était un grand magicien,
qui était considéré comme
un Maître magicien...
J'ai longtemps hésité à vous
parler de cette technique,
puisqu'elle appartient au patrimoine magique.
Et, en me renseignant dans
énormément d'ouvrages,
je me suis aperçu qu'elle appartenait
au Savoir en général.
Qu'un tour de magie ne peut
pas reposer dessus,
et que son explication est intéressante
dans le fonctionnement de notre comportement.
Le but de ce forçage psychologique est
de faire choisir, à une personne
1 objet, parmi 4 objets identiques.
Les mêmes ! Sinon ça ne fonctionne pas
ou ça fonctionne beaucoup moins bien.
Vous devrez mettre ces 4 objets
entre la personne et vous.
Un petit peu comme un chemin.
Je reprécise, encore une fois,
les 4 objets sont identiques
et ils doivent avoir, à peu près,
le même espace qui les sépare.
Et vous demandez à la personne en face de vous
de choisir l'un des quatre.
Donc de le prendre physiquement.
De le choisir !
Et le mot "choisir" est important
parce que ça veut dire qu'il y a
une petite réflexion qui va se faire.
Donc, vous devez la presser en
terme de timing,
mais elle doit réellement choisir.
C'est là qu'on voit le poids des mots
sur nos prises de décision.
Si je dis juste à une personne :
"Vas-y prends un objet, là, tout de suite".
Elle va prendre un objet donc,
peut-être le premier qui vient.
Si je dis : "Choisis un objet"
ça veut dire qu'il y a un petit processus,
conscient ou inconscient
qui va se faire à l'intérieur.
Avec un procédé de séléction.
Hey, hey !
Ça c'est intéressant.
Et pouquoi est-ce intéressant ?
Je vais vous le dire pourquoi
c'est intéressant...
C'est intéressant parce que la
personne qui est située ici,
va, de base, éliminer
- ou du moins avoir tendance -
à éliminer les extrémités.
Celle-ci et celle-ci.
Puisque les extrémités on l'air
vraiment différentes
parce que c'est quelque chose
de remarquable.
Donc, dans le choix, on se dit :
"Ben non, c'est trop évident
une extrémité."
[Homme derrière]  : Bonne année.
[Rires de Fabien]
Bonne année, abonnez-vous.
[A l'homme] : Je t'ai emprunté 4 cuillères
et je me suis permis de couper le son.
[L'homme - Ironique] : Tu as su comment faire ?!
Donc les extrémités c'est trop évident,
ça paraît trop évident à notre cerveau.
Et ensuite, quand on choisit quelque chose,
on a l'impression...
d'être moins évident dans notre choix
si on va chercher loin.
Dans la majeure partie des cas,
j'ai plein de statistiques,
j'ai lu plein de stats,
je ne vais pas vous les donner
puisqu'il n'y en a aucune qui a été validée
par un espèce de protocole qui nous permet
d'affirmer que c'est ce chiffre là
et pas un autre !
Mais on va dire : dans la majorité des cas...
c'est celle-ci qui va être sélectionnée.
Je ne sais pas si,
quand je vous ai fait la démonstration
là, tout à l'heure,
vous aviez eu cette tendance là ;
Je ne suis pas sûr que ça
marche bien en vidéo...
Néanmoins, ce qu'il y a à retenir
c'est que si 4 objets identiques
sont placés tel un chemin
entre deux personnes,
avec un écart équivalent
qu'on demande à la personne,
en face, de choisir un objet :
la personne va choisir le 3ème objet
en partant d'elle.
Pas les extrémités, pas le deuxième
mais le troisième.
Vous pouvez vous amuser
à faire ça,
c'est assez intéressant de
le constater.
Et depuis 2006 que
j'ai eu connaissance de ça,
j'ai eu le temps de l'éprouver
maintes et maintes fois,
et il s'avère que ça c'est très rarement
avérer différemment.
Alors moi j'ai monté
un petit quelque chose
qui me permettait de pouvoir
l'essayer en faisant un tour
sans me viander.
Je vais vous dire ce que
je faisais moi, c'est une idée à moi
donc vous en faites bien
ce que vous voulez...
Je mettais dans une enveloppe
un bout de carton.
D'un côté de ce bout de carton
il y avait marqué :
"Retourne la cuillère que tu as choisie",
et de l'autre côté :  "Tu choisiras
la 3ème cuillère en partant de toi"
Si c'était des cuillères !
Parce que sinon :
ça ne fonctionne pas !
[Bruits dans le fond]
Abonnez-vous !
Et je retenais, évidemment, de quel côté du carton
était marquée telle ou telle chose.
Bref, je mettais le carton dans l'enveloppe
et je posais l'enveloppe.
Oh ! Un petit pain au chocolat !
Alors : Team "pain au chocolat"
ou team "chocolatine" ?
Dites-le moi dans les commentaires.
[Au serveur] : Tu sais que ça, ça fout le bordel.
"Pain au chocolat", "Chocolatine",
mon gars...
Je prosposais donc à la personne
de choisir une cuillère,
sauf que dans  la deuxième cuillère
en partant de la personne,
c'est à dire, celle-ci.
Au dos, je faisais une croix.
Ou je mettais "Ok"
Ou je mettais "merci"
si j'avais un petit "Sharpie" qui
écrivait de manière fine et
que l'objet était assez gros.
Comme une carte à jouer par exemple.
Ce qui fait que je lui demandais
de choisir une cuillère ;
la personne n'a jamais pris
ni la première, ni la quatrième ;
ça, à chaque fois, il n'y a
jamais eu de souci avec ça ;
La plupart du temps, elle prenait
celle-ci, ce qui permettait d'avoir le carton
on le sortait dans le bon sens de l'enveloppe
et il avait marqué :
"Merci d'avoir choisi le 3ème objet."
là ça aurait été la 3ème cuillère.
Et si jamais c'était la 2ème,
dans les rares cas où c'était celle-ci,
et que, du coup, ça avait raté :
Je retournais l'enveloppe.
Je sortais le carton.
Donc là, du coup,
le côté visible du carton c'était :
"Retourne l'objet"
La personne retournait l'objet,
il y avait une croix ou "merci" ou "ok".
Je disais : "Tu sais que c'est là
parce qu'il n'y avait pas le choix ?"
Effectivement la personne
pouvait retourner les autres objets
il n'y avait rien d'autre derrière.
Voilà. Ça c'est une petite astuce si
vous voulez essayer en minimisant
le risque de vous tromper.
Vous pouvez faire ça.
Je range les cuillères tant que je vous parle.
Ça vous permet d'essayer,
de pouvoir voir les possibilités
et de pouvoir constater le
mécanisme de choix
comment fonctionne notre cerveau
quand on doit faire un processus
de choix comme ça.
On est, du coup, prévisibles
dans nos choix.
Vous savez, pour une prochaine vidéo
qui va sortir ce mois-ci,
je vais faire une vidéo avec
entre 25 et 50 abonnés
d'entre vous qui regardez
cette vidéo là.
C'est une vidéo qui va se passer par
Skype, donc je vais rencontrer
beaucoup, beaucoup de personnes
par skype ou en physique s'il y a des gens sur Paris.
Peut-être.
Ça c'est possible.
Je vais faire un tirage au sort pour ça.
Je ne vais pas faire le tirage au
sort sur la chaîne Youtube,
ce n'est pas très pratique.
Je vais le faire sur Facebook.
Sur la Fan Page Facebook.
Fabien Olicard, avec un petit trait à côté.
[ Fabien Olicard - ]
Vous avez le lien, de toute manière,
dans la description.
Si vous voulez faire partie du truc
vous allez voir directement sur la page,
il y a un commentaire
où je parle de ça.
Et vous mettez un petit commentaire
en disant : "Je veux bien participer."
Et vous ferez partie du tirage au sort.
Alors, comme d'habitude,
vous pouvez liker
ou vous abonner.
Et rendez-vous très bientôt.
Ciao !
[Musique Générique de fin ]